THE HOOK FOR BILLIONS IN
DAMAGES.
CHARLES?
>> Charles: SO WITH BIG-TIME
CELEBRITIES AND BILLIONS AT
STAKE, THIS CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT
BREAKING ATTENTION TO A MAYOR
FINANCIAL MELT DOWN.
LET'S GET MORE FROM MERCEDES
COLWIN.
MERCEDES, I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH
RESPONSIBILITY THESE
SPOKESPEOPLE HAVE TO HAVE.
WHEN YOU WATCH A SUPER BOWL OR'S
SEEN TIK TOK VIDEOS WITH TOM
BRADY AND HIS BOY, SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED.
THEY REALLY PUSHED THIS HARD,
WHICH IS THEIR JOB.
NOW ARE THEY CUPABLE FOR ANY OF
THE LOSSES?
>> THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
CARNAGE.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
REPRESENTATIONS WERE TO THE
INVESTORS.
IF YOU'RE THE AMBASSADOR BRAND
LIKE STEPH CURRY OR TOM BRADY,
DO YOUR DUE DILIGENCE.
KNOW THAT YOUR BRAND IS ON THE
HOOK NOW IN CASE THERE'S A
COLLAPSE OF SUCH -- LIKE THIS,
WHICH IS MONUMENTAL.
IT'S CATASTROPHIC.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A COLLAPSE
OF NOW PEOPLE ARE SAYING LIKE
ENRON.
IT'S LIKE MADOFF.
THE PONZI SCHEME.
IT COULD BE CRIMINAL.
ALL OF THESE TERRIBLE THINGS.
YOU KNOW THIS LAWSUIT, IF YOU
READ THOSE PARAGRAPHS, IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THESE BRAND AMBASSADORS AND SAY
YOU SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT WHAT
WAS BEING TOLD TO THESE
INVESTORS WAS COMPLETE
FABRICATION.
AND YET YOU PUT YOUR NAME ON IT
AND THEREFORE YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE.
SO THEY'RE ON THE HOOK.
COULD BE CONCEIVABLY.
>> Charles: I'M SURE WHAT THEY
WILL SAY, THEY HOODWINKED PEOPLE
IN SILICON VALLEY AND WALL
STREET.
TO YOUR POINT, A DRAWN OUT LEGAL
BATTLE WILL ZERO IN ON THE SCAM.
WHEN ALL IS SAID AND DONE, NOT
JUST THE MONEY, MERCEDES, BUT
THE WAY -- THIS IS AN EXCHANGE.
PEOPLE TRUSTED THAT THEY COULD
PUT THEIR MONEY THERE AND WOULD
BE SAFE.
THE FACT IS IT'S GONE.
SO SEEMS A LOT OF THESE MIGHT BE
SETTLED OUT OF COURT.
THEY'LL HAVE TO PAY UP, THE
CELEBRITIES.
THAT'S MY OPINION.
>> IT'S HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
NOBODY WILL SHED ANY TEARS FOR
TOM BRADY WHO IS WORTH $400
MILLION.
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY YOU SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN BETTER.
YOU'RE SURROUNDED BY THE BEST
LEGAL EAGLES.
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, THIS IS THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
YOU HAVE THE REGULATORS LOOKING
AT THIS, THE DOJ AND FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS SAYING LET'S FOLLOW
THE MONEY.
LET'S START FROM THE VERY FIRST
ENEXCEPTION OF FTX.
WHAT DID YOU TELL YOUR
INVESTORS?
WHAT TERMS AND CONDITIONS DID
YOU GIVE IN THE FIRST
DOCUMENTSES IN THE ENTIRE POOL?
THERE'S GUARANTEES THAT GAVE TO
THE PERSPECTIVE INVESTORS AND
SAID WE'RE NOT GOING TO USE YOUR
INVESTMENTS IN ANY OF OUR COINS.
GUESS WHAT?
THERE'S ALLEGATIONS THAT THE
COIN THAT IS AT THE VERY CRUX OF
THE COLLAPSE WAS A COIN THAT WAS
MONETIZED BY INVESTOR'S MONEY.
THAT IS ALL ALLEGATIONS.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW IT BORNE
OUT.
THE CLASS ACTION THAT YOU'RE
MENTIONING IS EXTRAORDINARILY
DEGREESSIVE.
THEY'RE DRAWING FIRST BLOOD.
THEY SAY FTX IS TO SAME.
>> Charles: I HOPE THAT WE LOOK
INTO THE POLITICAL ANGLE OF THIS
AS WELL.
THE NUMBER 2 DONOR TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
THEY SPREAD THE MONEY AROUND
GOOD.
MAXINE WATERS GOT SOME AND SHE'S
GOING TO HOLD A HEARING NEXT
MONTH.
SHE'S BEEN